Hello class, this
lecture will focus on
the pharmacology of
sedative hypnotics.
So in this lecture,
I will discuss
barbiturates, benzos,
ethanol, the Z drugs which
achieve CNS depression
by potentiation of
GABA, the inhibitory
neurotransmitter. So
I'll go through the
mechanisms and the
adverse effects and I
will distinguish the
newer drugs and the
benzodiazepines from
barbiturates and
ethanol. And the reason
being is that alcohol
and barbiturates are
not widely used anymore
because they are in
fact, based on their
specific mechanism
on that chloride channel,
can actually induce
respiratory depression
which is fatal.
I'll also talk about
non-sedating anxiolytics
and that will include
something like buspirone
or even the SSRIs.
I will talk about
other drugs that can
induce sleep and that can
include H1 receptor
antagonists that you can
buy over the counter
like Unisom or Nitol.
And lastly, I'll
talk about drugs that
are used for excessive
daytime sedation
and that's known as
narcolepsy and I'll
discuss the main
class which includes
amphetamines to
treat this condition.
So the first
four that are in
green are in fact
going to be the
ones that will
potentiate GABA.
And understand that
the degree of sedation
and hypnosis that
the patient will
in fact have will
depend on the dose.
And in this figure,
you can see that with
respect to drug A
and drug B, as you
increase the dose
of A, you go from a
sedation to an
ultimate coma where the
patient can have a
respiratory depression.
And drug A really
represents medications
such as barbiturates
and ethanol.
With the blue line,
that's going to
be drug B. And
that's going to be
really representing
benzos, maybe the
drugs that we consider
to be Z drugs.
And that happens to
be that there is going
to be a degree of
sedation and hypnosis
that occurs with
those drugs. However,
you can see that the
line plateaus, where
even if you increase
the dose higher than
what you need for
hypnosis, the patient
will not go into
respiratory depression.
Okay, and I'll
explain why
that happens in a moment.
So, borbitorates were
probably the first
developed, and they
include several
medications. they end
in barbital. I will say
that phenobarbital
is still used mainly
for epilepsy. It's
used first line in
newborns who experience
seizures. So say
they are born and
they're in withdrawal,
phenobarbital is
oftentimes used.
And they are considered
to be second line
for status epilepticus.
Status epilepticus
is a seizure that
occurs and it lasts
more than three to
five minutes. It can be
fatal. And usually the
first line is going
to be something
like diazepam or
lorazepam, which is
a benzodiazepine. And
oftentimes if that
doesn't work, you can give
phosphonatoin and
you'll study that
when you do
anticonvulsants, probably
in the next few
weeks, or you can
give something
like phenobarbital.
These drugs
are considered
to be lipid-soluble.
Biopental is considered
to be the most.
And this drug
specifically has
something called
redistribution.
And I'll explain this
concept in a few moments.
If you are an older
patient or you're
somebody that has
a hepatic disorder,
you're going to
increase the half-life
of this medication
class. And that can lead
to not only excessive
sedation, but it
can lead to the
respiratory depression.
And the elderly are
going to be very
sensitive to all of
these medications.
Because if they get
a higher dose or
the drug persists
in the body longer,
these patients
are going to
be prone to
getting falls.
And a fall in an
elderly patient
can sometimes be
fatal in itself.
The other thing
to note is that
barbiturates are
inducive as CIP,
cytochrome P450,
in the liver,
specifically
isoenzyme 3A4.
So inducing means that
you're going to get
a lower amount of
substrate. So if the patient
was getting, say,
barbitol, and maybe was
taking a medication
for contraception,
induction means that
the levels of the oral
contraceptives will be
lower and that can result
in pregnancy the
other thing that's
interesting is that there
may be an exacerbation
of perforia in those
patients that use
barbiturates and this
condition is where there's
a deficiency in an
enzyme that makes heme.
And incidentally,
barbiturates, due
to the fact that
they induce P450,
there may be an
increase in heme
itself. And that will
increase the risk
of this porphuria.
And with these patients,
and this is all
again occurring in the
liver, in these liver
enzymes, they may end
up getting confusion,
brown urine. And
so we say if the
patient has this diagnosis,
they should avoid
barbiturates. I think
they also would avoid
antibiotics like
sulfonamides as well.
And as I mentioned,
these can be used
for anxiety and for
insomnia, but given
the fact that we
have newer, safer
drugs, you're not
going to see patients
getting, say,
phenobarbital for sleep.
They're going to be
used specifically for
certain seizures, as
I mentioned, and the
induction of anesthesia
and that's going
to be thiopental and
redistribution is an
important concept for
you to to understand
this is you know this
whole idea of the
fact that thiopental
will cause a rapid
onset of anesthesia
but a rapid offset is
due to redistribution
so So for example,
diopental is going to
be infused and once
it gets into highly
perfused organs like
the brain, the liver,
and the kidney, the
patient will quickly
become unconscious.
So that would be probably
within 15 seconds.
The idea that it only
lasts 5 to 10 minutes
means that once it
does its job in those
higher areas of perfusion,
it's going to go
to the less perfused
area. And that would
include the muscle tissue
and the fat tissue.
So if, for say, if
you use thiopentol to
induce anesthesia,
it would probably be
the case that you would
use another anesthetic
to kind of continue
things along. But I
will say that thiopentol
with the drugs that
we have for anesthesia
is not as widely
used. I'm only saying
it because the concept
of redistribution can
appear on an exam.
So barbiturates,
okay, and here is
very important. This
is where barbiturates
and ethanol share
a similar mechanism.
They're going to
increase the duration
of GABA action. They're
going to open that
chloride channel.
The chloride is going
to flow in. That's
a negative charge.
That's going to lead
to hyperpolarization,
and that, in
essence, is going to
potentiate GABA and the
CNS effects. The
issue is that in order
for that channel to
open, it does not
need GABA to be included
on that channel.
And that is where
the issue happens,
because with the
others, you're going
to see that they
need GABA present.
Alcohol and barbitroids
don't. So because
of that, there is
no sealing effect,
okay?
And that now is going to
lead to CNS depression.
And the other
problem with
barbiturates and
ethanol is that
there's no
specific antidote.
The Z-drugs and
benzodiazepines
will have their
antidote, flumazenil.
These two don't.
You really got
to provide
supportive treatment.
Perhaps you're
going to need a
ventilator to maintain
their breathing.
And the other thing
is that you alkanalize
the urine. Because
barbiturates especially,
they will undergo
the ion trapping. So
if you're ionizing,
then everything goes
out the kidney. Because
remember, non-ionized,
it goes back, it
gets reabsorbed into
the cell membrane. So
that would be something
that's also specific
to barbiturates.
And as you can see,
the ethanol and
the barbiturate
binding site are
going to be slightly
different than
what we see for the
benzodiazepines.
Barbiturates
bind between the
alpha and beta
subunit. And again,
they don't need
GABA to work.
Barbiturates are
highly sedative
and they have a
hangover effect.
Again, that's because
of metabolites that
maybe can't go out
the liver and kidney,
especially in the elderly
where you're going
to see reduced hepatic
and renal function.
There will be
tolerance, and tolerance
means that you're
going to need
a higher dose to
get the efficacy.
So you put your patient
on 5 milligrams.
After a while,
the 5 milligrams
doesn't work.
You need a higher
dose. The patient
became tolerant.
And there's
also withdrawal.
And it seems to be
that those with the
shorter half-life
are going to be more
highly abused,
like pentobarbital,
and not because of
the high. And you'll
see this when I
talk about opioids.
Patients are not
abusing because
they're getting
high. They're
doing it to really
avoid the low.
And you'll see
in a moment that
sometimes we'll
actually use a longer
acting formulation
of that drug in the
same class to prevent
the withdrawal.
Meprobamide and
chlorohydrate, I will say,
you don't really have
to know much about.
Chlorohydrate
used to be used in
anesthesia, especially
in pediatric patients.
It used to be
available as a liquid.
They were taken off
the market, first
of all, for safety
and ***** potential.
And again, as I
mentioned, we have
other medications
which probably are more
effective with less
adverse effects.
Benzos will come next.
And I highlighted the
ones in green that
are probably going to
be the most widely
prescribed and on boards.
I'm not going to
ask you brand names.
You will need to
somewhat understand
the difference,
say, between
a long-acting and
a short-acting.
But I will never test
you on brand names.
So here is what
I'm trying to say.
Chlordiazoxapide and
diazepam are long
-acting. So if
we're talking about
alcohol detox, and
I'll probably expand
on this by the end
of this lecture.
When you are detoxing
somebody from alcohol,
you never want to
do this abruptly.
Because if you do, you're
going to get rebound.
And what can happen
is a condition called
delirium tremens,
where the patient can
have a seizure and
they can end up dying.
So the idea
here is you want
to give a long
-acting benzo.
And that basically
being long-acting
is going to keep the
patient, the GABA,
going. but they're
not going to have
withdrawal that is
going to, you know,
make them take
more medication.
Alpazolam is short
-acting. This is Xanax.
This is the one that
they use mainly for
panic disorder. Probably
it's the most widely
abused because of its
short-acting nature.
Lorazepam, clonazepam,
and diazepam are
used mainly for seizure
disorders. They're
considered to be
first-line for status
epilepticus, especially
lorazepam and diazepam.
They're also
available rectally,
so that can
help, say, if you
had a child who
was epileptic.
Midazolam is used for
anesthetic purposes.
It's been widely
replaced with
propofol, especially
for shorter-acting
procedures like
a colonoscopy.
Remamzolam is
a newer one.
This is for
those procedures
that are maybe
about 30 minutes,
okay? Maybe for a
colonoscopy. Again,
it's going to depend
on where you're
practicing because
certain protocol,
certain formularies
might approve one
versus the other. So
just remember that.
And this newer
one has a rapid
onset and a rapid offset.
And then Estazolam
and Fluorazepam
were used for insomnia.
benzodiazepams go
through the liver and in
the liver when we talk
about the long-acting
ones like chlorodiazoxipide
and diazepam
they're considered to
be the longest acting
diazepam is metabolized
to a metabolite known
as desmethyl diazepam
and the half-life of
that medication is
about 40 to 100 hours so
that's going to be great
if you're trying to
wean your patient off
say alcohol and you want
to prevent them from
getting a seizure
however diazepam would
be an absolute no if you
had an elderly patient
because that long half
-life of 40 to 100
hours would create
excessive sedation that
patient will wake up the
next morning and they'd
be groggy. If you
are thinking about your
elderly grandmother,
that can result in
dizziness and even a fall
and even confusion. And
that's why all benzos
should be cautiously
used in the elderly.
For the elderly, we
prefer probably
lorazepam.
Oxazepam and temazepam
can be used, but I
see that the one
that most physicians
will go for is
lorazepam. And the reason
being, it's going to
bypass phase one it's
only conjugated and
what does that mean
well remember phase
one back from intro to
pharmacology was your
oxidation reduction
and hydrolysis it
seems to be in the
elderly that's going to
be an issue as you get
older so if you give
something that is
only conjugated and
only goes to phase two
that's going to be
better for the elderly
patient if in fact
you need a benzoyl.
So again, here
is liver, and as
you can see,
chlordiazoxepam,
diazepam, they're
going to be, again,
metabolized as their
initial metabolite
as this methyl
diazepam. That's
the one that's
40 to 100 hours.
And then ultimately,
it becomes oxazepam,
it's conjugated,
and then it goes
through urinary
excretion. As I mentioned,
lorazepam, which is
the preferred one in
the elderly, just
gets conjugated and it
goes out the urine.
So we always prefer
this for the elderly
versus the others.
But again, if you
had that patient who
you're trying to wean
off, say, alcohol,
and you wanted
to prevent them
from getting,
say, a seizure,
these two that
have a longer path
to excretion would
be preferred.
so why benzos versus
barbiturates because
same thing is going to
happen they're going
to potentiate GABA
they're going to increase
the chloride channel
opening and they're
going to increase the
frequency but here's
the thing while the
other two do not need
GABA to open that channel
this group does need
GABA to work and
because of that there's
going to be a sealing
effect. And I showed
you in that first
slide, you get like a
plateau when you look at
benzos versus barbiturates
and alcohol where
there's no sealing.
Here's the thing,
even though on their
own, there is less
respiratory depression.
If you take a benzo after
a night of drinking,
I would say you need
to be very careful
you can go into
respiratory depression
if you took say a benzo
and you had fentanyl
in your body expect
respiratory depression
if you use benzo with
say even cannabinoids
you could expect
respiratory depression
so here's the thing
Patients need to be
cautioned that even
though you're not going
to expect respiratory
depression, if you're
putting it with
another medication, you
will get respiratory
depression and even CNS
depression, okay?
And this is another
thing. When you are
prescribing any of these,
okay, so you're the
physician, you're giving
a benzo for say, you know,
as an anticonvulsant,
you need to make
sure the patient
understands that CNS
depression will happen. So
they need to be mindful
if they are driving,
if they're operating
anything that needs,
you know, very, very
effective cognition,
because CNS depression
can be a problem. Okay,
so no driving when
you're taking benzos,
when you're taking an
opioid, when you're
taking alcohol, all of
that comes into play.
The use, as you can
see here, we have
anxiety, sedative
hypnosis, insomnia.
Antigrade amnesia is
an interesting one,
and that's the reason
why we use midazolam
for, say, a procedure
like a colonoscopy.
Antigrade amnesia
means that you don't
remember the event
that is happening
at the time
you're under the
influence of
the medication.
That would be a
good thing. Nobody
wants to remember
a colonoscopy. But
if you're thinking
about the date
**** drug, and I
showed it to you on
that slide with all
the medications,
flu nitrazopam or
ronhiponol, that's a
date **** drug. And
that was the big issue.
When people were
under the influence of
that, And that used
to be, and again, it
might still happen,
unfortunately, when
somebody illicitly
pours this in a drink,
well, what is
happening is, of
course, you get
sedation, and the
patient would not
remember the event.
They would not remember
that they were being
violated, and that's
because these drugs
cause the antigrade
amnesia. The other
thing is that you'll see
that these medications
can cause muscle
relaxation and it
seems to be because
benzos will calm motor
neurons and because
they're relaxing motor
neurons and also
decreasing the action in
the spinal cord, that
helps reduce spasms.
anticonvulsants i
already spoke about and
their role in in status
epilepticus and then
the next thing is
anticipatory nausea and
vomiting this i'll go
through next year when
i do anti-emetics this
is oftentimes given
maybe one dose before
a patient goes say for
some type of cancer
treatment chemotherapy
they're going to
be given a bunch of
medications you know on
the Ancetron or Epitant,
okay, you don't have
to worry about that,
but oftentimes patients
will say just the idea
of going back and
getting their chemo
infusions makes them
nauseous, so it's not uncommon
that the physician
may prescribe maybe
one tablet in the hour
before they have the
their chemotherapy,
but again, whenever we
would give this out,
we would always say
make sure you're not
the person driving there
and driving back so
with benzodiazepines
as you can see there's
going to be a little
bit of a difference
again we're binding to
the GABA receptor you're
allowing chloride to
come into the channel
to cause hyperpolarization
to enhance the
CNS depression that you
want but the binding
site is going to be
different than it is
for alcohol or barbiturates
And then again,
you have to have GABA
binding in order to
open this channel.
These two didn't, and
that's why those two
are more likely to cause
a respiratory depression
that can be fatal.
So as you can see,
as you increase
the log dose of
benzodiazepines,
you don't see much
of an increase
in the respiratory
depression.
With barbiturates,
as you see in the
red line, as you
increase the log dose,
you increase the
incidence of respiratory
depression. So this
is something you
really need to be
mindful of. Okay,
especially, again,
those that consume
barbiturates and, you
know, have a drink.
Very dangerous.
benzodiazepines their
adverse effects drowsiness
and hangover they can
cause some euphoria
and that's going to
be true especially
of the shorter acting
ones like alprazolam and
that's why it's going
to be more abused
than say diazepam the
antigrate amnesia i spoke
about which may be
a valuable thing if
you're doing a procedure
but it may be a crime
if you were if you
had a patient that was
in fact using was given
this and and they were
violated the physical
dependence again we
understand that there
are two terms physical
dependence is when the
patient will experience
withdrawal when they
stop the drug okay
and the other thing to
know is rebound anxiety
insomnia and seizures
so again with
something like alprazolam
if you were taking it
and you were abusing
it and you stopped it
abruptly that's going
to cause more of a
rebound effect patient
may even end up getting
a seizure because of
that so that's why if
in these detox mechanisms
you always would
want to use something
long-acting like diazepam.
I also want to
differentiate between
physical and psychological
dependence. As I
mentioned, physical
dependence is when you get
withdrawal symptoms
when you stop the drug.
Psychological dependence
is when you have
an intense need to
have it when it's
missing. You're not
going through withdrawal,
but you just know
that it's missing and
you need to have
it so that's the
difference between
physical and psychological
the other thing to know
is that these drugs
should not be given
in pregnancy it's been
shown that the babies
born to mothers who
have taken benzos will
have first of all there
may be some there may
be some effects where
there might be some
breathing changes,
number one. And the other
thing is that you may
get poor muscle tone
and sometimes it's
called floppy baby where
the patient, the baby
has almost like a doll
-like appearance where
their arms and legs are
almost like flopping
And that's due to
the poor muscle tone.
As I mentioned,
with ethanol and
barbiturates, it's really
supportive therapy.
But with benzos and
the Z drugs, which
you'll see in a
moment, we do have an
antagonist. And it's
known as flumazanil.
and this can
be given if the
patient is brought
to the hospital
and maybe has
taken, for whatever
reason, an overdose,
say, of clonazepam
and sometimes if you
use midazolam, say,
for a surgical procedure
and the patient
comes to and they're
still groggy they can
give some flumazanil
to offset the
benzodiazepine But the
thing to know is that in
the hospital, you
have to do this very
carefully. Because if
we give flumazenil to
somebody who's using
a benzo chronically,
that might actually
precipitate withdrawal.
So the idea here
is don't just give
flumazenil fast.
Make sure you do
it slowly so that
if the patient was
a chronic user and
you didn't know,
they would not go
into withdrawal.
so now we have
the Z-drugs and as
you can see that's
Zolpidem or Ambien
Zalpilon and
S-Zolpicholone
and these are interesting
unlike barbiturates
and even benzos they
don't really affect REM
sleep and the issue is
they have a shorter
duration of action and
because of that they
have less of a hangover
effect but here's a
couple of things that
we have to understand
you have to be able
to devote seven to
eight hours of sleep and
this is interesting
because if you gave
this medication say
at four in the morning
and you had to get up
at seven even though
we know there's less
less hangover there
would be if you had a
short amount of sleep,
okay?
So only give this
if the patient can
devote the 7 to 8
hours because if they
can't, they're going
to be very groggy
and they'll be
prone to falls. If
they have to drive,
they will be basically
hungover, okay?
the other thing is
you don't want
to give these at
all with other
CNS depressants
including alcohol
so if this patient
is taking this
medication and they're
going out for drinks
on a Friday or
Saturday they should
not get the Z drug
the other thing we
don't want to give
this for a long period
of time and I will
have to make you
understand for sleep
it's good to
know that there
are certain medications
like the Z drugs
and I'll talk about
the melatonin
agonist in a moment
but there's nothing
more important
than enforcing the
sleep hygiene because
you don't want to be
on these medications
for life so
again, avoiding
stimulants close to
bedtime, exercising
earlier in the day
watching your diet,
not scrolling, which
many of us do right
before bedtime, making
sure that when you're
getting ready for sleep,
you're doing something
relaxing. So just to
put that out there.
These melatonin agonists
have actually been
increased in use, so
to speak, in these
years because not only
do they not affect
GABA, they're not
controlled substances.
Okay,
so remelteon,
tasmelteon, these are
considered to meet
melatonin-1 and melatonin
-2 agonists. So by
binding to those
receptors and
activating, they're
increasing melatonin.
The only thing that you
need to understand
is that they are
considered to be
substrates for CYP1A2.
So for example, if
you're using this
medication, one of these
would say ciprofloxacin,
which is a fluoroquinolone
antibiotic,
cipro does inhibit
this isoenzyme. So you
may get an increase
in the melatonin
agonist, and that can
lead to more sedation.
Melatonin is really
where all of this came
from. and melatonin
itself is released from
the pineal gland and
it produces drowsiness
it also regulates
the circadian rhythm
melatonin is used
for jet lag some
people do use it for
sleep they have it
over the counter they
have it as gummies
I think it's between
1 mg and 10 mg
here's the
thing melatonin
is not FDA approved
remelteon and tasmelteon
is and here's the thing
if you told me that
a younger healthy
person was taking
melatonin once in a while
to induce sleep or
maybe for a few days
until they got better
because they've been
in Asia and now
they're off in their
sleep cycles now that
they came back home
I would probably be
okay with that But if
you're talking about
an elderly patient
who's on many medications
and is using, say,
an anticoagulant, I
probably would not
support that because
since it's not FDA
approved, there has not
been rigorous studies.
So we don't know
pharmacokinetics.
We don't know
drug interaction
information. So
again, that's
just something
to understand,
not just about melatonin
but about all
supplements.
So just to consider
that for the future.
Other sedative
hypnotics that have been
bought to the
market is something
called an orexin
antagonist. They call it
blockers of the OX1
and OX2 receptors.
Orexin is a neuropeptide.
It's made in
the hypothalamus. It
actually stimulates
appetite and has an
effect on cognition.
It supports sleep
and wakefulness.
So the idea here
is if you block
with something
like suvorexanth,
that's going to
induce sleep.
The thing to note is that
they are the newer drugs.
They have been definitely
approved, but they
are considered to be
controlled substance.
They have a schedule for
classification. so
patients can become
addicted to the
orexin antagonist.
H1 receptor
antagonists you've
studied hopefully
already.
And we have two
generations.
We have the first
generation, diphenhydramine,
doxalamine, which
you can use for
allergies. You can
use it for nausea and
vomiting, especially
with motion sickness.
And you have the
second generation.
like loratadine,
fexofenadine.
Here's the difference.
The first generation
are considered
to be lipophilic
and they cross the
blood-brain barrier.
And those are the ones
that can cause sedation.
Something like Allegra,
which is fexofenadine
or Claritin, the
reason why they were
bought to market is that
they were not lipophilic.
And because of that,
you could take your
allergy medicine, drive
to school you know
do your OMM lab without
feeling sedated so
if you have a question
about which drug do
we use for sedation it's
going to be generation
one okay the only
problem with generation
one is they have the
muscarinic blockade
so you're going to
expect dryness you're
going to expect urinary
retention which can
be a problem to say
older patients that have
benign prostatic
hypertrophy, they can cause
constipation, they
can cause tachycardia.
So these drugs, too,
should be used carefully.
And again, I would not
be comfortable with
patients taking it for
a long period of time
because there's also
a connection between
these medications and
long-term cognition.
And that can have
an effect on memory.
Patients that,
say, have AD or
dementia should
not be taking
H1 receptor
blockers as well.
Tricyclics,
doxepin, and we'll
talk about
tricyclics in a
moment and in a
future lecture.
Doxepin has H1
block. That's why
before we had
these medications,
some patients
would take Vaxapin
for depression and
they would be able
to sleep because
of the H1 block.
Trazodone, another
antidepressant, was used
to induce sleep because
of the H1 block.
And then I have ethanol
on the list. And,
you know, patients
will say, well, if I
have a drink at night,
it helps me sleep.
That may be true,
but we should
never encourage
patients to use
alcohol for any
of these purposes.
And the other thing to
know is whenever you
give ethanol with any
CNS depressant, that
can be a problem.
Whether it be if they
need to drive or it
could be, in certain
cases, an increase of
respiratory depression.
So I always like to
review past concepts in
my lecture. I want to
say the H1 receptor
and maybe the alpha-1,
just as another review
point, are going to
follow a GQ mechanism.
So histamine binds to
the receptor. You're
going to increase protein
lipase C, and that's
going to increase
DAG and IP3, which is
going to allow now,
through the action of
protein kinase C, to
get more calcium inside.
That makes sense. If
I'm thinking about
alpha-1 and the action
on the arteriole,
and I'll probably say
this again in the future,
that action of A1-alpha-1
agonism in the arteriole,
more calcium in is
going to cause more
contraction. and more
contraction means
vasoconstriction.
And that makes sense.
Alpha-1 agonists are
going to increase
vasoconstriction
and they'll increase
blood pressure through
that mechanism.
So tricyclics,
again, I don't want
to talk much about
them. I will say
that in order to
treat depression,
they're going to
inhibit the reuptake
of norepinephrine
and serotonin.
So what does
that mean to you?
Well, more
norepinephrine and more
serotonin here are
going to bind to
the post-synaptic
membrane and that's
going to help with
the depression.
But tricyclics,
they also block H1.
And what does that
mean to you? Well,
they're going to
cause more sedation.
But on the
flip side, they
also will block alpha-1.
If you're blocking
alpha-1, I just
mentioned, And
instead of getting an
increase in blood
pressure, there's
going to be a
decrease. And that's
where you get
orthostatic hypotension.
So the patient gets
up, and the next
thing you know,
they feel dizzy.
They feel like
they're going to fall.
And then if you're
blocking muscarinic
receptors, you're going
to get what I just
told you. You're
going to get urinary
retention, constipation,
dry mouth, dry
eyes. If you are somebody
that has now even
glaucoma, that's
going to complicate
because muscarinic
block causes medriasis.
So again, these
concepts will be covered
throughout the semester
and even next year.
But start to understand
what these receptors
do and what blockade
will also achieve.
So ethanol, as
I mentioned,
will potentiate GABA.
Okay, so that's going
to be responsible
for the CNS
depression effects.
Ethanol, just like
barbiturates and benzos,
will open that
channel to allow
chloride in. The
negative charge is
going to cause
hyperpolarization and
you're going to
get CNS depression.
But ethanol and
barbiturates, and I
know I'm repeating
myself, but it's an
important concept.
They open this channel
without GABA needing
to be present,
and that's going
to produce the idea
of increase in
respiratory depression.
The other thing is
that ethanol inhibits
the NMDA receptor
for glutamate.
Glutamate is the excitatory
neurotransmitter.
So what will
happen is that if
you block NMDA with
chronic alcohol
use, NMDA is going
to be upregulated.
And that's going to be
responsible for
the tolerance,
dependence, and
also for some of
those withdrawal
effects. And I'll
explain that when I
talk about some of
the drugs that we
use for withdrawal,
like acomposate,
in a few minutes.
So ethanol,
acutely, may cause
some, of course,
euphoria.
And that does
make sense, if you
think about it.
When you have a
drink, you feel
nice and relaxed.
But again, if you
keep drinking,
even in an acute setting,
you're going to
become impaired.
It's going to change
your cognition.
So that's why it's
important that
we always are
mindful how much we
drink and what we
do when we drink.
Driving,
operating machinery,
things of that nature.
But chronic alcohol
use is going to affect
many other things.
Number one is something
known as dilated
cardiomyopathy, where
mitochondrial dysfunction
and the production of
ROSs, reactive oxygen
species, are going to
have some effect on the
contractile proteins
in the heart, and
that's going to affect
the left ventricle.
and that over time may
lead to a patient
having a problem with
their heart, mainly
congestive heart failure.
The other thing
is something known
as Wernicke's
encephalopathy.
This means that over
time, you're going
to deplete your
thiamine stores. You're
going to get a
thiamine deficiency.
and that decrease in
thiamine in the brain
means that now you
don't have enough
glucose for brain
function and that is going
to affect neurotransmitters
it's going to
have an effect on
again oxidative stress
and with this condition
when the patient is
brought into the
hospital who is going to
be very confused, is
going to be talking
about things, making
up stories, because
they're having an effect
on brain function,
you would have to give
thiamine first before
the glucose, because
without the thiamine,
the glucose can't
really do its job.
Alcohol can cause
fetal alcohol syndrome.
if you're thinking about
pregnancy and
fetal development
ethanol, aspirin,
and phenytoin and
you'll see it later
is going to exhibit
a zero-order kinetics
zero-order elimination
in that no matter
how much of this
drug you give it's
not going to change
the elimination
rate and that means
toxicity is going
to be pretty severe
Ethanol will also
induce CYP2E1 And if
you're using
acetaminophen or Tylenol
with ethanol That's
going to create more
hepatotoxicity That's
why on the box of
Tylenol They always
say if you're
drinking more than 3
alcoholic beverages per
day You should not
take acetaminophen
Ethanol does increase
inflammatory mediators
It also increases
the risk of cancer.
And by now we know
that many cancers are
attributed to
excessive alcohol use.
And then, of course,
we always know that
the main organ is
going to be the liver.
Again, that has to do
with the idea of ROSs.
So ethanol is going
to be broken down by
alcohol dehydrogenase
to acetylaldehyde
and then acetylaldehyde
dehydrogenase makes
it a water soluble
compound which is
excreted and that's
acetic acid When there's
much ethanol consumed
there's going to
be a change in the
NADH to *** ratio So,
high NADH is going
to result in some
of the problems
that we see, where
lactate accumulates.
You're going
to get an increase
in fatty acid.
So,
again, fatty
liver can be other
things, but
another contributor
is excessive alcohol use.
And then you lose
glutathione. And
glutathione is produced
in the liver, and it's
considered in very
simple terms to be
our body's own natural
antioxidant. So
if you're missing
that, that's why ROSs
start forming and
creating more damage.
So ethanol goes
through an oxidative
mechanism. So that's
considered to be
phase one. And I'll
talk about other
drugs that affect
this pathway, such
as aldehyde dehydrogenase
in a moment.
Fetal alcohol syndrome.
Again, the most
critical time for fetal
development is the
first trimester and
that's you know something
that is sometimes
difficult because there
may be some patients
that don't know they're
pregnant for a while
and they may be
still using alcohol
they may be using other
medications so that's
why you know going
through prenatal care
is just so important.
And this is some of the
physical
manifestations of FAS.
There can be other
things where the child
may have some disabilities
with learning.
But just a mention about
fetal alcohol syndrome.
And again, the zero
order, as I said,
a constant amount of drug
is eliminated per time.
So you're not
changing the rate just
because you're
adding more drug.
So the line is going to
be the straight line.
Somebody is intoxicated
with alcohol.
They may have
slurred speech.
Nystagmus, which
means it's a rapid,
involuntary
movement of the eye.
They'll be sedated.
They may be in a
stupor or, in a worse
case, in a coma.
Hypotension can
occur, and that
might be due to
the fact that
There's more nitric oxide
produced in the
endothelium, and
that can increase
vasodilation.
With vasodilation,
you may get an
increase in
neurotransmitters, and
that norepinephrine
gets to the heart,
and that may
cause tachycardia.
Hypoglycemia may
be due to the fact
that you're impairing
gluconeogenesis
in the liver. So
the patient is
going to have a
lower blood sugar.
Lactic acidosis,
when you're
increasing NADH,
you're shifting your
pyruvate to lactate.
And that's where
you get the
acidotic condition.
Hypokalemia and
hypomagnesemia
may be due to
the fact that
the patient may
be dehydrated.
Maybe they're vomiting.
The other thing
with dehydration is
that there may be
an inhibition of
antidiuretic hormone.
And if that happens,
you're going to
lose more fluids.
With alcohol, just
like barbiturates,
there's no
specific antidote
like flumazenil
for benzos.
So you're going to
provide supportive
care. You're going
to make sure the
patient's respiratory
airway is preserved
with a ventilator.
And remember, if
you're pulled over
80 mg per deciliter,
you're considered
to be intoxicated.
As I mentioned,
alcohol withdrawal is
something that has to
be done clinically.
Patients should not
do it at home because
the idea of them
getting a seizure is
really high. So they
really need to be
managed clinically in
a hospital setting or
a detox setting when
you do withdrawal.
So in an overdose,
I already said it,
you maintain the airway.
You provide
supportive care.
So you're watching
their blood
pressure, their
heart rate.
You're looking to
see about their
electrolytes, their
blood glucose.
the symptoms of
withdrawal can be cns
stimulation or in
worst case the delirium
tremens and remember
with the cns stimulation
they could be
anxious they can have
some degree of tachycardia
palpitations as
you see here so what
you want to do number
one to prevent the
seizure is to give
the long-acting benzo.
So we like to give
chlordiazoxapide or
the diazepam. And
remember from that
slide that I had at the
beginning, those are
the two that are going
to have a long half
-life because they
have to go through
phase one and then phase
two metabolism before
they're excreted.
Then we have alcohol
use disorder.
And there's
several ways we can
manage the patient.
Number one,
we have a drug
called naltrexone.
And naltrexone, I'll
talk about in opioids.
It's considered to
be an oral opioid
antagonist. But here's
the thing that makes
it very valuable for
alcohol withdrawal,
is that it decreases
the reward and the
cravings because it has
a decrease in dopamine.
Remember, dopamine
is responsible for
the reward phenomena
behind addiction.
Then we have a newer
drug, or maybe it's
not new, but they're
using it somewhat more,
is acamprosate. And
as I mentioned, with
chronic drinking, you're
going to have an effect
on the balance between
GABA and glutamate,
with GABA being the
inhibitory and glutamate
being the excitatory
neurotransmitters.
So this medication is
going to restore GABA.
And by restoring GABA,
you're going to get
some degree of CNS
depression. So the patient
is going to be more
calm in presentation.
And as I mentioned,
with chronic
alcohol, you
are getting an
upregulation of
the NMDA receptors.
So this medication
will stop the NMDA
receptor upregulation.
And that stops
the excitability,
so that too can be
more of a calming
effect on the patient.
And you could also
do CBT, and that's
important. Patients
should not just rely
on medication. They
should have some
degree of talking to
professionals that
can also assist them
in this condition.
In the past, we
had disulfiram.
and this was
known as Antabuse.
And what this
medication did was
to be a deterrent
because it
blocked aldehyde
dehydrogenase.
And that's going to
be used, the enzyme
used to convert
acetaldehyde to the
water-soluble,
excretable acetic acid.
If you're blocking
this enzyme, you're
going to increase
acetaldehyde and
that's going to cause
a horrible reaction.
The patient is going
to be sweating.
They're going to be
experiencing
palpitations.
And because of that,
we don't want to use
that anymore because
it's actually, it seems
like the treatment is
worse than the cure.
But I will bring
this up because
later on, when I talk
about chlorpropamide,
which is used
for diabetes, or
metronidazole,
which is commonly
given for giardia
or trichomoniasis,
we have to tell
our patients
not to drink
alcohol because
they can increase
this action.
Acetylaldehyde
being high can cause
flushing, nausea,
vomiting, and palpitations.
And then formipizol
is interesting
because this is going
to be the antidote
for those patients
that drink,
mainly children, if
they get into the
garage and they
drink antifreeze,
you want to give this
from epizol because
by blocking alcohol
dehydrogenase,
you're going to stop
the metabolism of
that toxic alcohol
and it'd be eliminated
quickly. And
that's an antidote.
So that's just a
little bit about that.
Clonidine is an alpha
-2 adrenergic agonist.
It's going to work
presynaptically. It's
going to reduce
norepinephrine in that area.
And because of that,
it does have an
effect at reducing
the sympathetics that
is involved with
withdrawal, whether it
be alcohol, opioid,
and even nicotine.
The issue is that it
can cause sedation. It
can cause some degree
of depression in the
patient. And of course,
since it's decreasing
norepinephrine
presynaptically, it will
lower your heart rate
and blood pressure.
Anxiety is actually a
natural pattern
of behavior.
Because if you were
not anxious and
you saw, say, a
bear in the woods,
you would not run.
So anxiety, to a
degree, it does
protect us from harm.
The problem is when
you have too much
of these transmitters
and it starts
to affect the
patient's daily life.
And the idea here
is the transmitters
are coming from
the amygdala and
they include the
standard glutamate,
GABA, serotonin,
and norepinephrine.
Benzos are the most
widely used group
of anxiolytics, but
they're only to be
used for short term
because we do worry
about the possibility
of addiction.
So what we tend to do
for panic disorder,
we would start the
patient on the alpazolam
to stop the acute
episode and then we
would give something
like an SSRI or even
Buspirone for the
generalized anxiety.
Propanolol I
need to mention
because we do
have a condition
known as
situational anxiety.
The patient has not
been diagnosed with
anxiety at all, but
they're doing something
that causes them
to be anxious. So
for example, they have
an exam, they have
to perform as a
violinist in a concert,
giving propanolol is
effective because,
number one, by
blocking norepineprin,
you're going to decrease
that sympathetic
overdrive, and
that makes sense.
The second thing
is that if you gave
something like this
before performance,
you're not going
to get, number one,
any addiction
liability like
you would if you
took a benzo.
And the other thing,
you won't be sedated.
You would not want to
take a benzo before
an exam because you
don't want to be sedated
while having to
concentrate. So giving
propanolol would be
effective for this reason.
The only problem is
that propanolol being
non-selective is
going to block beta-2.
So if you have an
asthmatic patient,
a diabetic, or
somebody with PVD,
blocking B2 in the
lungs is going to
cause more of a
problem with breathing.
It's going to
cause bronchospasm,
so that would be a
contraindication.
Buspirone is a
serotonin 1A agonist.
It has no effect
on GABA. it does
have some weak
dopamine blockade.
And it is used for
chronic anxiety.
And one thing to
know about this
medication is that
it has no dependence,
there's no tolerance,
there's no rebound.
So this is why
you would start
the patient on
the benzo and then
switch them over
to buspirone.
The other reason why we
need to start patients
on a benzo is that
this drug, along with
the SSRIs, take a
while to work. There's
probably about four to
six weeks when the patient
really gets full
effect. But definitely
in the first two weeks,
as the patient starts
to get adjusted to
this medication, you
would want to have a
benzodiazepine on board.
And I just want to say
that serotonin itself,
even though we use it
mostly for depression,
and you'll see the
SSRIs are used for
major depressive disorder
in a future lecture,
serotonin enhancement
does calm patients down.
The other thing is
that the partial D2
activity does have
an effect on anxiety.
Adverse effects can
be some dizziness.
Narcolepsy is considered
to be a situation
where the patient has
daytime sleepiness.
Even though they're
getting enough
sleep, they will
complain that they
can't get their
job done because
they're very sleepy
during the day.
How you manage is by
giving a sympathomimetic.
And you also use a
sympathomimetic for
attention deficit and
hyperactivity disorder.
Amphetamine,
dextroamphetamine, and
methylphenidate, they work
to do two things. They
inhibit the reuptake
of norepinephrine and
dopamine. They also
increase the release
of catecholamines from
the nerve terminals.
The adverse
effects can be by
increasing norepinephrine.
You're going
to get an increase
in heart rate,
maybe an increase
in blood pressure.
That increase can
also contribute
to weight loss and
even anxiety because
I explained before
that increasing
neurotransmitters,
norepineprin,
GABA, can have an
effect on anxiety.
Modafinil and ometafinil
are newer drugs.
They have a greater
effect at the reuptake
and release of dopamine
versus norepineprin.
That means, since
there's not much effects
on norepinephrine,
you're going to have
less anxiety and less
of the weight loss.
The only issue is that
it does cause skin rash.
And the other thing
is that it activates
orexin and inhibits
GABA. And I
explained to you
before, orexin blockers
were used to induce
sleep. So it makes
sense if you're
activating orexin and
you're also inhibiting
GABA, you would
probably be able
to not feel sleepy.
So again, going
back to this
picture is
very important.
The difference
between ******* and
amphetamines is
that ******* is a
reuptake inhibitor
of dopamine and
norepinephrine,
mainly dopamine.
Amphetamines can
do the same thing,
but they also
allow for the
release of these
neurotransmitters.
Modafinil is going
to be interesting.
It's going to
have an increase
in the release
of dopamine.
And that, in
fact, is going
to increase wakefulness.
No effect on GABA.
orexin will in fact
be increased and
that's going to enhance
alertness and the
same thing with
histamine because I
explained that a
histamine blocker is going
to be used for
sedation if you're
increasing histamine
you're going to be more
stimulated so that
does make sense so
in summary you can
say that blocking
histamine will in fact
cause more sleepiness
but increasing histamine
would cause more
alertness. And we'll
talk more about
histamine in future
lectures, especially when
it's involved in the
allergic process.
This lecture is going
a little over. I
realize it, but I don't
know any other place
where you may have
some of this. And
this is important when
it comes to boards.
When patients overdose
on stimulants,
especially if we're
talking about *******,
some of the symptoms
are going to be
hard to differentiate
from schizophrenia.
And I'll talk about
those medications
in a later lecture.
So the patient will
be in somewhat in
a delusional phase.
They will be
hallucinating.
And on an autonomic
perspective,
they're going to have
tachycardia. They're
going to have
medriasis because
you're turning on
sympathetics, so
you're thinking about
fight or flight.
They will be hypertensive,
and that causes
in the heart may be
due to the increase
in norepinephrine
that I mentioned.
They will have
hyperthermia,
and they will
have seizures.
So for the hyperthermia,
we probably
will do some degree
of cooling blankets.
That's considered
to be the supportive
therapy for that. But
the other thing you
will notice is that
they may experience some
type of tactile
sensation that they feel
like bugs are crawling
all over them.
And we call that
******* bugs. That might
be due to the hallucinations
that are being
caused by the reuptake
of the dopamine.
How we manage is we
acidify the urine
because these drugs
are considered
more basic in
structure. So by causing
acidification, you
ionize and the rest
of the drug goes
out in the urine.
Supportive therapy,
as I mentioned,
the cooling blankets,
the lorazepam
for the possibility
of seizures,
haloperidol, which
is going to block D2
that is responsible
for causing some
of these delusions
and hallucinations.
And lastly, to
relieve the autonomic
effects on the heart,
we give labetalol.
And the idea here is
most patients think,
what about propanolol?
And the problem with
propanolol is that it's
only going to block
the beta receptors
against norepinephrine
in the heart. You need
something that's also
going to participate
at blocking the alpha
receptors. And the
betalolol is considered
to be a mixed alpha
and beta receptor
antagonist. So that's
usually the right choice.
and that's it for now.
Lastly, I want to talk
about sodium oxybate
and this is going
to treat a condition
known as narcolepsy
with cataplexy and
cataplexy refers to
the fact that the
patient is getting a
loss of muscle tone.
So this medication
is considered to be a
salt of gamma
-hydroxybutyrate It's known
as GHB, which itself
is an illicit drug.
It's a metabolite
of GABA, and this
drug, as you can
see, is going to act
as an agonist of
the GABA-B receptor.
Has a very strong half
-life, but by acting
as an agonist here at
both the GABA-B and
the GHB receptor,
what you're going to
get is an induction of
a deep sleep. And that
is said to help
patients that have this
narcolepsy with this
loss of muscle tone.
The issue, since
I mentioned that
it is considered
to be GHB is an
illicit drug, you
need to be enrolled
in a program known
as Risk Evaluation
and Mitigation.
It's called REMS.
And this is where it's
not dispensed from
a normal pharmacy
where the doctor
writes a prescription.
It has to go to a
central pharmacy,
which monitors the use
and prescribing of
this drug. It will also
have certain paperwork
that is going
to be involved in
letting the patient know
the risk for *****
and what to avoid.
In adverse effects,
patients can become
more nauseous They can
become more confused
And if this is ever
taken with ethanol or
sedative hypnotics
You're going to increase
respiratory depression
So that's why
having it in a REMS
program is going to be
very important Because
that information will
be communicated to
the patient The other
thing about sodium
oxybate It's not uncommon
that the patient will
get this medication
at night and maybe
during the day get an
amphetamine like we
talked about before,
like dextroamphetamine,
amphetamine
itself, maybe
even modafinil.
So in summary, I want
the students to really
understand the mechanisms
of these drugs,
some of the more
important adverse
effects, and again,
the differences between
even drugs that are
considered to be gabaminergic,
the difference
between barbiturates
and ethanol versus
benzodiazepines, some
of the drugs that
we went through for
anxiety, like the idea
of using buspirone for
generalized anxiety
disorder, and these
drugs for narcolepsy.
I will be doing the
question review, which
I know will be helpful
in going through this
lecture, which I do
realize there's a
lot going on here. So
do listen to that
review because it will
help you kind of cement
all these concepts.
If there are
any questions,
please let me know.
Until then, be
well and I will
see you soon.